sur la partie historique entre la partie
qui était avant cela la grande ceinture
entre saint cyr il y à pereire
c'est comme un train ça veut dire que
les stations sont un peu plus d'espacé
et la vitesse maximum est plus
importante elle peut aller jusqu'à 100
kilomètres heure alors que sa partie
urbaine tu vraiment la vitesse est moins
importante puisque l'on est sur la
voirie donc le tram va
limiter sa vitesse est limitée à 50 km
heure est donc là on est sur deux
parties bêtement classiques comme un
tramway
on va commencer à tester
la signalisation donc le que les feux
passent au vert pour le tram une
priorité au tramway il faut bien qu'elle
ait des feux et puis la puissance
électrique il faut que la puissance et
vitesse soit suffisante pour que le tram
puisse accélérer au bon moment et ça il
ya un gros travail au niveau des sous
stations électriques pour vérifier que
les sous stations électriques
fonctionnent bien et donne au moment la
bonne puissance électrique
on va commencer la mafia bleu la marche
à blanc c'est l'opérateur de transport
donc les auditeurs qui vont commencer à
travailler sur la ligne à blanc comme si
c'était normal mais sans les voyageurs
ça c'est utile pour former tous les
moniteurs et puis tous les personnels au
centre de contrôle et au centre de
maintenance pour que les personnels pape
commence à maintenir les drames et les
infrastructures comme en situation
réelle
[Musique]